men who have gut fat are perceived to be
better fathers this is compared with a
guy that's in good shape and you think
hang on a second how is the guy that
isn't able to protect his family because
he's less physically formidable going to
be perceived as a better father and the
reason is that the guy who has more gut
fat is seen to be less potentially
attractive to other mates which means
that if he is given one calorie there is
less likelihood of him spending that
calorie on trying to acquire a new mate
because more doors have been closed to
him than the guy that is in good shape
and may potentially have more doors open
to him I think that being less uncertain
about your partner strain contributes
massively to a woman who might have
anxious attachment or maybe there's a
disparity mate value there that she is
going to feel a lot more comfortable
with that but the wild thing when you
think about this is that Comfort
contributes quite a lot to woman's
arousal and there is a situation in
which someone who was less in good shape
would be more arousing and more
attractive to a woman because her degree
of comfort would be increased